[Music]
okay so welcome everyone and thanks for
coming to our talk it's a full full
house
so today we want to talk about some
brick Matic approaches to causal
inference my name is Dennis I'm a data
scientist a big data Republic and I've
been working at at haineko
my name is hype and I'm working on a go
as a data scientist okay so what is this
thing causal inference so basically what
it's about is inferring causality we
might be interested to know what the
effect of some action is such as
drinking a glass of wine a day on your
health and well as Vincent implied
casual inference in this case would be
inferring some effects directly only
from this action as you can imagine
there may be common factors that
influence both this action we may call
it the treatment as well as the outcome
so that's what we're interested in today
how can we accommodate for that
introducing some notation actually
common factors W is the treatment and Y
is the outcome so when I start sort of
with a with our slogan for the talk
experiments you thought were good can
still be invalid and experiments you
thought were bad can still be valid and
that's because in the context of calls
or inference an experiment is usually
the way that people go about it yeah so
how does it works how do you normally
set up such a randomized test well
normally what you do is you have a
population of people you're you're
interested in this could be the
population of the Netherlands for
instance or just all the population of
the world you take a sample and you make
sure that the sample is representative
of the whole population then you split
the sample into two groups you make sure
that the two groups are random you apply
an action to one of the two groups you
measure the difference even calculate
the average effect of your treatment all
well and good so let's take a look at
the use guys this is use case I've done
together with Dennis at an ACO where we
installed heat power
in people's homes the goal is to reduce
gas usage of home by installing an
electric heater so that the electricity
usage may rise a little but the gas
usage overall will decrease a lot which
is nice for sustainability things and
things about this so what do we have we
have daily gas data of the homes and if
we look at gas data in correlation to
outside temperature you'll see that as a
very strong yeah temporal effect so in
in cold days you'll see a lot of gas
usage and in hotter days you'll see very
little gas usage this is a very
nonlinear effect so in the summer you
won't use any gas for eating but in the
winter you will so by doing this kind of
experiment you can immediately see that
the the red line is before installing
the heat pump and the green and the blue
lines are after installing the heat pump
so you might say ok this is a very good
indicator that the heat pump is actually
saving energy but how much and how can
we say more about it well we'll do the
same type of experiment so we'll take
the population of the Netherlands take a
random sample no doesn't work because
we're only we can only look at a very
small subgroup of people in the
Netherlands for instance people that
have a tonne so we have historic data
they also need to own the homes because
we're going to do quite an invasive
thing in their home we're going to
install a heat pump next to their CV
installation or a central heater boiler
so we're already filtering quite a bit
of population then this population we
have do we learn at least split it
randomly no we also can split then split
randomly because we have to ask people
if we can install such a thing and it's
basically done the reverse so we ask
people to apply for this and to make
sure that they're really they want to
participate in this as also the
test in the control group are likely not
the same or not representative of each
other then we're going to do the
intervention so we're gonna install the
need pump and we want to make sure that
at least this is the same for every
people for everyone that's participating
it's also not the case as you can
imagine if you install the device in
people's homes it will probably not be
the same day for each each and every one
of them because there will be people
that not at home the devices might not
be ready you might not have mechanics to
install them so generally in our
experiment we noticed that there were
several months between the first and the
last a participant where we installed a
heat pump it's quite a big problem so
again we don't at least measure the
average treatment effect yes we still
can although you might want to run away
from the problem so how do we how do you
do this this first thing how do you
match the test and control group if
there's such a large imbalance well
luckily for us we do have a lot of
co-variants about a lot of population so
we can correct for the for the things we
know are different between the entire
population and our sample and between
the control and test group so what we
have is we have for instance the size of
the ohm the building type built period
people that live in a home etc but how
do you do this matching because you can
imagine if you just take all different
combinations of factors that you have
and the number of combinations explodes
very quickly and the chance that you be
able to match someone to a large enough
group to say something about it becomes
very small so instead of doing an exact
match we say okay I have a house in 1936
with four people of 150 square meters
and I want to match only people with the
exact same characteristics we couldn't
do something else who can do a partial
matching we just choose people that are
very similar and the goal of this of
course is to make sure that the
distribution the test group becomes the
same as a distribution of the control
and one way to do is is by a propensity
score matching and the concept is not
very difficult but it's nice to see in
action so what we have is we have a test
person in that test a and the population
and we calculate the chance of receiving
treatment based on the things we know
about the control and test so in this
case is 38% and all the people in the
control group we do the same then we
match the test group to the most similar
people in the control group we let the
other people go away and we just
calculate the effect for both groups and
we have corrected treatment and we can
do the same for all the people in the in
a testing control group and you'll have
an average effect of your entire test
group so in our case for the heat pumps
this means that the even though the
experiment fails almost all the
assumptions you have to make or you
normally make about such an experiment
each of these faults can be corrected by
measuring months even though you need a
year so you're just using the graph I
showed you earlier extrapolate to make
sure that you have the data you want and
to correct for the bias in the test
group you match with the people in the
control group using the propensity score
the outcome here though is the the
average effect of the test group not
over D of the whole population so if you
really wanted to know what the effect is
of the population you'll still need to
correct for that and we cannot say
anything about rental households because
we just eliminated them from both the
control and the test group completely so
if you want to make sure that you can
say something about the whole population
either night need to make very strong
assumptions about the the effect of
having a rental versus a mount household
for instance by saying yeah having the
house doesn't really make any difference
it's just about levels of insulation or
the mean temperature in
home things like that things I'm so I
just took us through one concrete
example of applying causal inference in
a business context in terms of
propensity score matching so I'm just
gonna look at a different one when I
said Heineken we were doing a project on
cooler placement so we have some sort of
outlets and it has a certain yearly
profit that we didn't measure as a
company and we're interested to see what
happens if we if we place a cooler in
this outlet so how much does the profit
go up so again we start with a certain
population in this case this was one of
Heinekens operating companies 13,000 off
trade outlets these are small
mom-and-pop shops and they're selling
Heineken beer brands and they may or may
not receive a cooler so the first step
is we're gonna take sort of a random
sample from this population actually
there were okay because this is actually
an observational study so the careers
have already been placed and we're
actually measuring sales in all of the
outlets so our sample is in fact the
population so that's a good thing but
then when it comes to randomly
subdividing this into two groups this is
where it fails because obviously the
coolers have already been placed and
it's been done on the discretion of some
sales representative who decides whether
or not the outlets is good enough as
good business practices in order to get
a cooler and yeah these these good
business practice outlets
they're called gold outlets and you have
silver and bronze as well so then maybe
we can try and have a similar
intervention for all the people getting
his cooler for all the outlets getting
into cooler arms also not the case
because they've been placed over a
period of many years and it's even worse
than the case with the heat pumps
because actually these guru movements
are not tracked so they've only started
tracking this last year so I mean you
know where the coolers are right now
which is also an interesting scenario
that you might run into so what can we
do we can take the last year's profits
as an indication and then try yeah and
then just assume that the treatment
effect over years is constant and so you
don't have some rebound
fact that the profit goes down after an
initial period and then yeah well
treated as experiment that way so can we
at least calculate the average treatment
effect well we could but we're not
interested in this because we want to
actually use the output of our model to
prioritize new cooler placements so it
actually means that we want you know we
actually want a distribution of
treatment effects over these outlets and
if you ask me an average treatment it
doesn't give you anything to go on so at
this point again we may be tempted to
run away but do not despair so first of
all I mentioned this thing about these
gold outlets so here you see just some
distributions of the profits for no
cooler singled or cooler double the
recorders over the three different
rankings ratings and you can clearly see
how for the profits is generally lower
with a large number of no cooler and
bronze outlets moving up to the gold
outlets so obviously this ranking is
that the only thing that influences the
placement or the treatment in this case
so we have other things other Arctic
characteristics like the sub channel
area type the area itself sub
seasonality store the only opening
summer or winter Heineken has
interactions with these outlets so they
actually have sales reps visiting them
making sure that the execution is done
that the viewers are placed correctly in
the quarters they make some estimation
of the competitor presence in the
outlets who make deals with the outlet
owners we invest in them we have
branding materials and we can get maybe
some external data as well so some
demographics maybe from some national
bureau of statistics and google maps
metrics so you may think well why are we
spending so much time on these features
but they're really important because you
really have to in these situations it's
all about your features shift to think
about what influences both my treatment
and my outcome and these things you
really need to capture in your model so
just a quick example to show you how
what you affected this is so I've just
created artificial example with only one
covariant which is the gold ranking yes
or no
we've profits
it's a base profit that's slightly lower
for the non gold outlets as you can see
and you also see that the probability of
placements we've generated here is zero
and one this year on one race and the
probability of placement is slightly
higher switch 2/3 in the gold outlets
and they've also imposed my own
treatment effect so this is a simulated
example so that we can really see in
hindsight different method works and the
prefix also higher and these gold
outlets so to start just one thing
that's relevant to note is that even
conditional mean so you're probably all
familiar with it but it's a mean of Y
for different values of X so it's
basically what you're usually doing when
you're fitting a model and you're using
a prediction that's basically a
conditional mean so what if we just
subtract the average profit for the
treated and the control groups we see
something weird happening here we get
treatment effects of 6.04 but that's not
possible because we know that the lowest
possible treatment effect is 3 and the
highest possible is 5 so there's
something really out going on here let's
break this down per group so what if we
look at only the gold outlets and we
actually just leave all the non-road
outlets out and then calculate the
difference we actually get back to this
this five
if you increase the end here it's a it
approaches five and the same goes for
the non gold outlets okay so that makes
sense we're back at our initial example
but we've actually done here is we've
calculated the conditional expectations
given the fact that X is a certain value
so maybe we can extend this into sort of
a general estimation methods okay so
just a question for you what would be
the effect of all the imbalance in
treatment caused by the gold ranking is
improved is removed so a 50% of outlets
are gold and probability of placement
were equal for all of them what would be
the effect anybody know
treatment effect for the non gold
outlets was three and the gold outlets
was five anybody okay so it's four it's
exactly in the middle because we've
actually balanced these two groups okay
so what's the procedure for this with X
X bar the sample mean of the covariance
we fit a regression on to an intercept
the treatment itself the covariance and
the demeaned interaction between the
treatment and covariance we could just
read off the coefficients on W being the
average treatment effect so what it
looked like we just create a new
variable this is the mean interaction
term and fit a linear model and redock
of the coefficient and yes we get our
treatment active form one thing that's
really important to note and I mentioned
it before this really big assumption at
play here
it's called conditional mean
independence and what we're saying is
actually is that we can at least on
average remove the dependence between
the treatment and the outcome Y by
conditioning on some variables in this
case X these are confounders or our
covariance provided that they're
observable there's also called strong
ignore weak ignore ability and the
provider observable is very important
because if you're you know you're trying
to based on the main expertise trying to
collect as many covariates X as possible
and then you think that you've got the
multi-cut might still be some hidden
factor that seems so influencing both
you don't capture your model you'll
still have bias this also makes these
models very hard to validate because all
real life situations all real life dyes
data sets will not actually have the
treatment effect measured because you
don't know that for every individual you
don't know both the outcome in the
treated case in a non treated case so
you also always have to either
synthesize some data or use some
randomized control trial data but you
remember we're interested in individual
treatment effects or not an average
treatment effect so here we have a new
assumption actually and it's a little
stronger assumption it's strong ignore
ability
we're actually assuming that any
independence over the whole distribution
of wine X their independence once of our
ynw once we condition on X and this is
important because we're going to
actually also estimate a whole
distribution over the whole feature
space of X one thing to note here I'm
just going to talk about one approach
has some others but yeah if you want to
know about them later I can tell you
there's lots of interesting research to
being done into this and they all
started the paper saying we assume
strong ignorable and then you know move
forward from there
but this in practical situations is
going to be your biggest bump so I've
found that it doesn't really matter
which specific algorithm or approach you
choose because they're going to be you
know improving some bias in the in the
margin it's mostly about your features
so you really need to choose the right
features okay so this one approach
called virtual twins it's actually quite
simple
we're just fitting some sort of tree
ensemble or a decision tree but
preferably obviously to prevent
overfitting ensemble model on the sales
or profit in this case and then we're
just going to include the covariance as
well as the the treatment variable as
features in the model
so just like you were doing any other
prediction case what were they going to
do is once we fitted this model
between the target Y features X and
interactions between X and W and this is
we don't need to demean them in this
case because these three methods are
insensitive to feature scaling and then
we're just going to predict all units
change w21 change that with a zero and
take yeah sort of the prediction for
each individual case as an individual
treatment effect one thing to note here
it's very important that you prevent
overfitting so think ways to do it early
stopping like in gradient boosting
techniques and use out of bag
predictions and also you can use
quantile objective quantum object
function I'll show later how I did this
in order term outlet so just take the
ones that you're most certain about and
don't consider the rest there's other
approaches there's some interesting deep
learning ways to do tackle this and
another one is also using three ensemble
by actually creating first a propensity
tree model and then using the leaves to
calculate the difference between
treatment and control groups but in this
example I've just taking this one so how
does this look in practice we started
with this this is a group of thirteen
thousand outlets actually there's a
slightly smaller sample I think here
because these are all the outlets that
we selected for this round of the
experiment and on the x-axis you'll see
the predicted profit by a model and the
y-axis we can see sort of the yeah the
profit that we've they've actually
measured this past year so this is just
also a way to see how good my model
working r-squared of about 50% so first
we're doing is actually we're trimming
everything at within a quantile band of
90% so we actually just considering
those outlets that are yeah we're
reasonably more certain of the of how
good the model performance is I'm going
to select we're actually calculating
this up potential uplift in case of an
upgrade for all the outlets and
selecting the ones with the highest
uplift so we can see that I've selected
quite a few outlets that don't have a
cooler yet which you would expect but we
can also select out let's have a small
cooler and upgrade them to a bigger
cooler and these arrows here just
showing how the profit would go up in
case of this this placement and the new
situation so strongly nor ability in
this case was probably a bit of a harsh
assumption to make but and especially if
you're looking at cases like in medicine
you really want to be accurate on your
individual pace patients but in some
business context you may say well at
least in the group that I've selected
for my treatment on average in this
group the treatment should be okay
should be what we expect if if your
business context allows basically has
some error on individual cases
okay let's recap so your perfect
experiment will likely be ruined by
harsh reality what this means is that
even though you might have the ideal
conditions in your head or on paper some
business guy will come along and say
we're gonna change it a bit we're going
to choose people differently than I
would might want it but you might still
be able to fix it for instance by using
prevent propensity score matching too to
match again the testing control group or
your whole population and the sample and
by doing average or individual treatment
effect estimation we're just correct for
the fact that the people you're looking
at are not the same as the people you
want to know things about then to make
this work you really need to collect
enough data so all the factors you think
or people in the business think might
influence the effect you need to measure
this also means that you need to keep
very good track of how your experiments
actually performed so when is the
treatment applied to whom measure things
correctly make sure you don't lose data
make sure you don't flip things and also
to make sure that you yeah basically
measure everything you want to know
about individuals so this can be done by
just sending out question lists or just
measuring things but it is really
important because as Dennis said before
the biggest buyers in your model will
not be the machine learning model you
choose whether it's linear regression or
a very fancy deep learning model it'll
be the data you put in because the
biggest effect is always the effect you
don't know okay well thanks this is our
talk I will have some time for questions
I think and if you're interested about
in this use case we've lots of other
interesting use case designing and
coming up in their global insights labs
we do projects for for operating
companies all over the world and they're
looking right now for senior data
scientist in your data engineering so
have a look at that
[Applause]
yeah so the question is basically that
if I recollect correctly that if you
take people from rub-on you take people
from Absalom then they will probably not
be similar in many ways for example
whereas people from Devon think yeah
I think I think we concluded Heineken
will not be a sponsor next year well
done and the question was what if you
have not enough people in bonds to
really make the case that you can model
things would it be the same as saying
okay we have a bit of a prior that we
can establish beforehand before doing
the entire experiment oh yeah oh yeah
that's that's very possible
yeah so the question was how big is the
influence of the ranking of the outlets
or gold bronze or silver and what
happens if it actually changes during
your year of measurement so we're just
using the last known ranking what they
usually do is they've explained this
personal so it's important to know how
your covariates are created so in this
case once every year they create sort of
scoping for the whole market and then I
also change these change these rankings
and here and there so it could happen
that whilst you do an experiment they've
changed the ranking yeah and that's a
limitation
so the question was do you have some
sanity checks to know whether your
conditional mean independence holds so
this this this is a bit of a death trap
because in one way you'll never know
right because there's always there can
always be some selection bias you can
never really verify it so I think talked
yesterday but Lucas gave some really
interesting insights into what's just
seeing what happens how good is your
predictive probability of your
propensity score so that's a good one
how good is the model fit on your
propensity score so the predicting the
probability of treatment and another one
would say from a purely political
perspective do a proper research where
you use lots of different estimators
different time periods different types
of measurements and see if they all come
up with the same answer it's obviously a
bit tedious and finally some approach
could be using instrumental variables
and that's when you have some feature
that actually predicts treatments but
does not predict the outcome and then
you can actually apply an instrumental
variables approach to you know to have a
sort of an unbiased view of the
treatment effect
right so the question was and if we're
going to use the bottle now to do the
allocations how will it influence for
next year this is a classical problem in
machine learning right because it's like
when you're you have some call center
that's or some intelecom company you
have a department that actually filters
certain problems with subscription
payments and then you build a model on
those late on that label data and then
you're actually replacing those people
and then it becomes a sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy it's the same
problem here so you need to make sure
that the all the features you use your
model are still going to be independent
of the use of the model itself so if
these these sales reps are going to say
well the model says is a good outlet so
I'm going to improve the ranking that's
not something you want because then
you're actually yeah creating your own
reality as you're saying it's an answer
your question now so use the model to do
the allocations but don't influence the
the covariances you're using in the
model don't change those yeah yes yeah
they're all out-of-sample so some sort
of cross-validation strategy yeah just K
folds yeah
just shuffle splits you might want to
choose a high number of folds because
otherwise the the predictions can be
quite unstable on individual outlet
basis